I spot Haley in the back seat and yes
that's Drake pulling up to the nice guy
in LA last night but it was ladies first
as a young Baldwin made her entrance
into the restaurant following closely
behind Drake what up Dre it was actually
the pair second stop as TMZ spotted them
having an intimate dinner at Isabel
earlier in the evening on Monday hailey
and Drake were looking cozy on snapchat
using the dog filter at Drizzy's
Memorial Day party hailey was so low the
morning after but wait isn't that a
Toronto Raptors jacket she's wearing I
mean we all know Drake is the team's at
global ambassadors so it looks like he's
been spreading the love south of the
border with Haley the two also showed a
little affection back in November at
Kendall Jenner's birthday party at the
time Haley was rumored to be dating
Bieber as they shared way more than a
peck on the cheek over New Year's
remember that while the two always
insisted they were just friends bieber
and drake are definitely friends as
Justin showed up at drake's album
release party in April and he's even
rumored to appear on an upcoming remix
of Drake's number one song one dance and
Haley told British Vogue she has no
intention of choosing between the two
that's not
can't make me shoes like that I'm picky
but like then don't tell him I said that